uh I can't prove that we don't have a
constitution anymore and I
and I'm not sure I would want to but I
can give you a few vignettes I think of
indicates if it's not if it's not dead
it's at least sick or uh ailing
these examples I'm giving examples
mostly from uh the question of what the
rule of law means in the Constitution
and what we're doing today
about uh with respect to that
and I will give three broad three areas
I want to talk about one the
intelligence agencies second the
Judiciary and finally
the response of governments at all
levels to the covid panic
my focus isn't so much on this or that
particular Clause of the Constitution
but rather
uh the big picture the Constitution As
Americans have understood its broad
meaning
and purpose through most of our history
and by broad meaning I mean
the Constitution is a foundational
document our foundational document and
does two things establishes a republican
form of government for the for the
nation
and rules the people through laws
that are are meant to apply equally to
persons equally situated similarly
situated
and and the uh
and and these laws uh
approved by elected officials are meant
to provide protection for life liberty
and property and I'll amend that to say
temperate Liberty
and responsible ownership and use of
property is how is this the way this is
the way the Constitution has been
broadly understood and uh in 2017 after
Trump's election he criticized the claim
made by the FBI the CIA and other
intelligence agencies that Russia had
interfered in his election
uh
Trump said nonsense
at that point senate senate minority
leader Chuck Schumer
uh told Rachel Maddow
that Trump is quote being really dumb
unquote to say that quote and now and
now quote
the money quote from Schumer let me tell
you you take on the intelligence
Community they have six ways from Sunday
at getting back at you end quote
that I think uh is a is a vivid
statement
of where we are in regard to the rule of
law and relation to the intelligence
agencies
basically Schumer was boasting
that about uh you know that didn't
matter that Trump had been elected
they were these intelligence agencies
are going to find a way to harm him
because he had said things that they did
not like
he was uh and which really implies that
in a really important case like who's
President and who and what what the
president gets to do
uh the consent of the government is not
the primary consideration
intelligence agencies uh if they if
intelligence agencies can harm elected
officials at will when they deviate from
the line laid down by the ruling class
then uh then the consent of the
government has been replaced by
something different
and uh and at the same time
if they were if they are able if the
intelligence if the agencies are able to
harm Trump or anyone
uh the uh
they they would that implies they have
the power to deny the protection of the
laws to anyone
he just happens to be the most prominent
at that moment and the most important
from their point of view
they have six ways of some from Sunday
to get their way on anyone
if Schumer is right the two main things
that the state and federal constitutions
were designed to do are being denied
first government is supposed to secure
these rights through even-handed
prosecutions and punishments
of the criminal law
and civil law but and and especially
with the protections of due process and
equal protection
the idea that citizens have a right to
defend themselves when accused
and that there are the and that the laws
will be applied equally equally people
will be equally protected no meaning
whoever commits a crime will be
prosecuted no matter what the class sex
race status is of the criminal and
similarly
the race sacks or sex or class class
status of the victim
uh if Schumer is right though then this
the state these this is being denied
because the uh in the way that I've just
described the these policies
what is it that these intelligence
agencies care about I can summarize in
this way
uh what they what the intelligence
agencies want and of course lots of
allies in the federal bureaucracy as
well as the states
and elected among elected officials too
to some degree is uh they want a
government
that supports that
whose policies abroad spread the liberal
world order all over the world
uh is our idea of Liberty is to be every
is to be is to be spread everywhere if
need be by force of arms
uh something that Trump questioned in
the campaign
uh the the government uh that they
prefer
it pushes policies that support special
privileges for the disadvantaged
including blacks Latinos women gays and
so on
and they also promote policies that that
Advance the ever more radical separation
of sex from Marriage
and the denial of politically relevant
differences between men and women
this was not a theme in the campaign
2016 campaign
but it is an ongoing theme in our in our
political life and these and the people
who who are in these positions to be
able to harm
are very concerned and committed to
those causes
now I should add finally that while
being committed to doing good for others
in these ways as they seek doing good to
others as they see it
there's always one notice is a concern
for one's own doing good for oneself
uh looking for a job maybe in Raytheon
or in some NGO that pays lots of money
or maybe CNN there's there's uh there's
this constant churn between politics and
and the private sector called private
sector
in these ways
which uh which which one sees especially
in these intelligence agencies lots of
EX agents lots of ex-employees appear on
networks uh TV networks
uh so but but this is the thing the rule
of law is so fundamental to the
Constitution that it that it that it
accounts for the basic structure of
government itself Article 1
the legislature is supposed to make the
laws Article 2 the executive protects
the people's Liberty and property by
taking care that the lobby Faithfully
executed
and then article 3 judiciary
under the laws passed by Congress they
are supposed to determine the legal
rights of individuals in prosecutions
and lawsuits
today if the intelligence agencies
decide that they disapprove of the laws
or the president's faithful execution of
the laws or judicial determinations of
cases under law they have the power to
prevent that's from uh from from being
done
by threatening or actually harming
members of any of the three branches
now I mentioned Trump the case of trump
there are many other cases uh you know
Tim weiner in his book on the CIA talks
about the way that the CIA was involved
in destroying the career of Joseph
McCarthy it's this has been going on a
long time
our lunchtime lunch speaker has found
has looked into the role of the CIA and
the FBI in the
what became almost the impeachment of
Nixon that definitely driving him out of
office so that was that's all this has
been happening for for quite a while
now as it turned out in the Trump case
he was right and Schumer was also right
uh that is TR the two-year Mueller
investigation found no evidence of
Russia collusion
which means that the claim made by the
quote 17 intelligence agencies unquote
during the 2016 campaign was proven
false or wildly exaggerated
and the Durham investigation found that
there had there had never actually been
a legal basis
to justify the investigation of Russia
collusion
an intelligence agency is partly
responsible for
creating a fictitious you know creating
a supposed legal base turned out to be a
fiction
but Schumer was also right in predicting
that these agencies would have their
Revenge
Trump came into office intending to
create better relations with Russia
but the actions of these agencies and of
course their spokesman in the media
uh really en forced Trump to change his
policies Trump was was consent was being
confused over and over again of treason
by having wanting to have good relations
with Russia and against the background
of the Russia collusion charges
he was pressured into basically
reversing his policies and becoming a
much more harsh towards Russia than he
intended to be
uh so in fact in short in the accusation
of the of Russia collusion
had a crippling effect on the first two
years of his presidency
uh now I could mention also this the
last two years of his presidency with
all of the Ukraine stuff it's another
again it's another example I'm not going
to go into
but what uh finally I wanted to bring up
this point that one of the one of the
efforts of the agencies
to prevent Trump's re-election in 2020
was a it was a letter signed by 53
former employees of the agencies these
intelligence agencies falsely claiming
that the New York Post Post Revelations
of the of the 100 Biden
laptop information which was which
contained information about Trump
engaging in corrupt deals
um
Biden
sorry
yeah I mean that was it yeah Biden
wasn't was shown to be engaging in
corrupt deals and the uh but this was
but they but you know everybody's
everybody in the intelligence agencies
former employees to be sure oh no that
could never happen and then of course it
turned out to be true as we now know
uh and not only that but they they
managed of course because they had they
had made this claim government was in a
position
to pressure and the agencies were in a
position to pressure the private sector
social media in particular and and also
the public media
so in the places where Americans mostly
get their news and social media and
public media
uh internet internet media
there was a kind of blackout on this
whole topic during this 2020 campaign
some observers believe that that alone
that inner that election interference
alone was sufficient to carry what
turned out to be a very close election
for Biden
uh leaving aside the question of of
other kinds of possible cheating in the
election which I do not rule out
the uh now the um
when when Schumer implied that the
agencies suffered no consequences
whether or not they followed the law
he is certainly there's there is
evidence to say to show that that's true
uh I was thinking of the case of Peter
Navarro which come up recently he's been
prosecuted this year for contempt of
congress when he refused to testify
against his boss
his base his crime was right not I
didn't show up to testify
now James Clapper back in 2013 during
the Obama years was Director of National
Intelligence
and he was never prosecuted for lying to
Congress
he testified in Congress that the NSA
had been had had not been illegally
compiling data on American citizens in
violation of the Fourth Amendment
Edward Snowden revealed that Clapper who
was lying
Not only was Clapper not prosecuted the
White House immediately announced that
Obama had quote full confidence unquote
in him that's what happens if you're a
member of the intelligence agencies
they have six ways from Sunday to come
after you and you can't touch them
foreign
and of course Snowden got the whole six
ways from Sunday treatment right they've
basically made it clear to him if you
come back here you'll be in prison for
life
uh he's currently living in Exile in
Russia
uh my second set of examples come from
the Judiciary uh of course it's not just
the intelligence agencies who are
involved in
undermining the rule of law in America
uh they too are involved in this whole
process and I I'm going to use a quote
from the 1960s
when the Judiciary became increasingly
unmoored from statute as well as
constitutional law in my opinion at
least
symbolizing that shift away from resp
respect for an enforcement of law
was the influential David basilon he was
chief judge of the D.C circuit in the
1960s and 70s
one of his former clerks Alan dershowitz
has this explanatory or this quotation
if it if a defendant deserved compassion
but no formal legal remedy was
technically available to him
basilon would wink at me
an order that I find some ground for
issuing a writ of rock bones
rachmanas is the Hebrew Yiddish word for
compassion
so in other words if there was no formal
legal remedy that was technically a
meaning it wasn't the law didn't support
the outcome that's just you know
technically didn't support the outcome
yeah it didn't support the outcome
that basilon wanted so the wink and the
and the writ of rachmanus basilon's
purpose was to change the law wherever
he had the opportunity to conform to the
view that the law should not be like the
famous statue
where Lady Justice is blindfolded
holding the scales
right she doesn't see who the parties
are in the case she's just applying the
same standards of both sides
and what basilon together with his
friend uh justice Brennan and other
Supreme Court liberals did
was to rip the blindfold off of Lady
Justice to tell Lady Justice to make
sure you know who who you know who whom
right who's benefiting and who's being
harmed
and make your judgment on the basis of
which side is the disadvantaged or the
downtrodden or the victim